une jolie bonjour merci d'être avec nous
discours du trône le jeudi on avait
parlé beaucoup de cette nécessité cette
volonté de tendre la main et vous
l'impression que l'étendue la main les
partis d'opposition est tout à fait
parce que c'est vraiment con du trône
sous le signe la collaboration on s'est
inspiré plusieurs bonnes idées qui avait
été présenté par les autres partis que
quelques bonnes idées
quelques bonnes pas du nom quelques
bonnes idées que ce soit bien entendu la
baisse d'impôts pour la classe moyenne
sur laquelle elle aussi votre idée
c'était notre idée mais il y avait quand
même une volonté du parti conservateur
d'aller de l'avant
on s'est inspiré de toutes les caisses
de toutes les questions en lien avec
réconciliation avec les peuples
autochtones environnement tu t'es rock
qui proviennent particulièrement jane [ __ ]
et puis aussi pour la question de la
femme à coeur en anglais donc
l'assurance donc dans votre tête vous il
y en avait pour tout le monde
oui mais en même temps on est le
gouvernement on est élu pour gouverner
et donc on arrivait aussi avec nos
propres priorités
premièrement l'abordabilité donc le coût
de la vie on sait que le coût de la vie
au canada coûte trop cher on veut faire
en sorte de diminuer de 25 % les frais
divers
on veut baisser les impôts on veut
s'assurer aussi de continuer tout ce
qu'on a fait pour nos familles donc la
location canadienne pour enfants
deuxième point le contrôle des armes à
feu train polytechnique a eu lieu
vendredi 30 ans 30 ans puis souvent
d'inaction au niveau du contrôle des
armes à feu
on veut aller de l'avant c'est
fondamental on sait en plus qu'une
augmentation des homicides violée par
par arme à feu
particulièrement en ontario donc on veut
faire on doit agir sur cette question
question là et finalement
l'environnement il ya des éleveurs
évidemment qui sont des discours y en a
d'autres qui sont pas des mots qui ont
été retenus saskatchewan alberta pétrole
pipeline c'est pas mentionné dans le
document de dix pages pourquoi mais
parce que le programme a pour nous la
protection de l'environnement elle est
fondamentale on sait par ailleurs qu'il
ya deux provinces au canada dont
l'économie est vraiment basée sur
l'exploitation des hydrocarbures qui se
font les gens en alberta en saskatchewan
revient j'étais là et on a l'impression
que c'est pas reconnu dans un discours
que vous avez l'impression qui a pas de
yahia ya pas de prise de conscience des
problèmes
là-bas ces gens n'ont pas voté pour vous
et ils ont déconné économiquement il
souffre et on n'en fait pas mention d'un
discours mais j'étais à edmonton ya à
peine trois jours j'ai eu l'occasion de
rencontrer les gens là badminton avoir
de bonnes conversations avec les leaders
du milieu des affaires avec les employés
de l'agencé de développement économique
le premier thème du discours du trône
c'est le fait qu'il ya des tensions au
sein du pays mais surtout des réalités
économiques qui varient on sait qu'on a
créé un million d'emplois au cours des
quatre dernières années mais on sait
aussi que le succès de ceux de ce boom
économique la hap a été ressenti par
tous et donc on doit agir c'est
mentionné dans le discours du trône que
on doit être là particulièrement pour
les employés qui ont perdu leur emploi
et donc on doit s'assurer que alors
qu'une transition énergétique tels est
juste et équitable mais ce que serait
pas être un beau message de mentionner
spécifiquement juge pour dire on a
compris qu'il y avait un problème
spécifiquement labaki on va sauver mais
parce que on le sait aussi que il y a un
enjeu entre les régions rurales et les
centres urbains
on le reconnaît c'est pour ça aussi que
le promu nice même un homme est aussi en
charge du développement économique pour
aborder vraiment adressé cette question
là et je vais y travailler bien entendu
le discours du trône est une façon pour
le gouvernement d'indiquer quelles sont
nos intentions mais le détail c'est
vraiment dans les led demanda de chacun
des ministres lettre de mandat qui vont
être rendus publics sur riesch all au
québec non plus pourquoi ben en fait le
québec et le pays c'est ce n'est qu'un
alors on veut faire en sorte justement
de soutenir tout ce qui est la priorité
des québécois qui est particulièrement
la protection de l'environnement
on arrive avec des mesures très
spécifiques que ça soit pour soutenir
vraiment l'achat de véhicules hybrides
et électriques pour vraiment tout ce qui
est rénovation construction de nouvelles
maisons de nouvelles habitations
écoénergétique
on arrive même aussi avec notre grande
intention qui est de faire en sorte
canada qui est par ailleurs un pays qui
dépendent beaucoup de l'exploitation des
ressources naturelles qu'on soit un pays
carbon nutsie de massacre qu'est ce que
vous avez pensé de la réaction de vos
collègues jeudi après un discours du
trône et des autres participent à ce
qu'il y ait vraiment on a clairement
compris que vous alliez survivre se fait
là parce que le bloc a dit 'nous on y
avec son l'appui les conservateurs ont
rapidement dit nous on n'aime pas ça va
tenter de l'amendé les livres
eux ils disent on aimerait ça jase et
puis voici a pas place aux négociations
ça vous dit quoi ces réactions mais
c'est normal pour l'opposition de réagir
comme ça il ya un peu de théâtre là
dedans mais il y aussi parce que ils ont
été élus sur la base de leurs propres
plateformes donc ils veulent pousser
leur propre idée
mais en politique c'est pas vrai que
tous nous divisent ya plusieurs choses
qui nous réunit est donc l'idée c'est de
faire en sorte de pouvoir aller chercher
certaines certaines des priorités des
autres partis pour arriver à une forme
de consensus et au final gouverner dans
l'intérêt médailles seulement mais en
même temps cette idée d'essayer d'amener
tout le monde de travailler ensemble
aller dans la même direction 80 des
réactions comme ça aussi
quel point ça mais on est un
gouvernement progressiste c'est un
discours dutronc progressis qui tend
vers la gauche parce que dans le fond
c'est l'essence même du parti libéral du
canada pour nous on croit au filet
social
on croit au fait qu'on doit avoir une
société plus juste on se croit aussi
qu'on doit en faire plus en matière de
protection aux environs de
l'environnement on est le gouvernement
qui ne le fait plus au cours des quatre
dans nos amis on doit aller plus loin et
c'est pour ça qu'on va bien s'entendre
avec avec nos collègues et on va
continuer ou en même temps notre jeu de
parlementaires bon secours du tour vous
l'avez distincts et non c'est une idée
parce que vous êtes feuille de route si
vous voulez est ce qu'on peut s'attendre
escurat du concret et dans quels
secteurs plus particulièrement au niveau
de l'énoncé économique par exemple au
niveau du budget qui ça vient peut-être
en t2 vous voyez quoi le se développer
très rapidement parmi les idées les
grandes idées qui ont été mis là mais
vraiment premièrement en 2015 est arrivé
avec le premier projet de loi qui était
sur une baisse d'impôts pour la classe
moyenne
pour nous c'est la pierre angulaire de
notre action politique
c'est sûr qu'on va te laver encore avec
une autre baisse d'impôts ça c'est la
première chose parce qu'on sait qu'on
vous doit vraiment continuer à soutenir
dans le fond notre économie mais aussi
que les gens doivent avoir accès en fait
à une qualité de vie qui a du bon sens
donc première chose deuxième chose
vraiment tout ce qui est en lien avec la
protection de l'environnement je viens
de vous en parler
on a parlé aussi de la réalité du
contrôle des armes à feu
la question de la sécurité je pense
c'est quelque chose qu'on va voir un
petit peu plus dans notre mandat et puis
finalement la réconciliation avec les
peuples autochtones et la place du
canada dans le monde
donc vous voyez vraiment où les les
aspects
gouvernement pour pour ce qui s'en vient
puis oui le budget va avoir plus
d'informations oui les nôtres économique
potentiel va avoir plus d'informations
mais je vous dirais que ce qui est
vraiment là où on va chercher
l'information complet c'est dans les
lettres demande parce que là vous allez
savoir vos ministres c'est quoi le
boulot qu'ils ont de la partie un des
éléments qui est pas mentionnée en vue
d'un discours du trône par messieurs
qu'on a autre chose dont on parle dans
des mines entrevue c'est toute la
question des langues officielles
c'est vote d'ausy oui vous êtes
responsable de ça oui il ya de grosses
grosses attentes en matière de langues
officielles entre autres sur toute la
réforme que vous avez promis durant la
campagne
pourquoi ce n'est pas là mais c'est
mentionné ce qui est mentionné dans le
discours du trône c'est le fait qu'on
doit protéger nos minorités
linguistiques
c'est une mention évidente et donc par
la suite dans les lettres de mandat on
va plus dans le détail et on s'est
engagé à non seulement moderniser la loi
sur les langues officielles que 50 ans
mais la renforcer alors je confiante
qu'on va pouvoir avoir un bon mental
il a une jolie c'est votre deuxième
mandat oui ces minorités oui le premier
majoritaire vous avez pas été beaucoup
le saviez comment ces mini sentez vous
la différence qu est-ce que vous sortez
c'est sûr que l'anr pour moi c'est une
nouveauté
j'ai post j'ai jamais travaillé dans un
contexte minoritaire mais j'aime bien
m'entendre avec mes collègues j'ai un
réflexe de bien m'entendre avec monsieur
bull reste avec multi delta les et aussi
avec monsieur fortin mais avec mes
collègues de façon générale donc le fait
de négocier de collaborer je pense que
personnellement motors ça va être un
plaisir
maintenant c'est sûr qu'il ya une
réalité aussi en tant que les listes
qu'on doit être davantage à la chambre
des communes salle bouleverse un petit
peu notre horaire ça fait en sorte
parfois qu'on est un petit peu moins sur
le terrain parce que justement on écrit
pour avoir mené en majorité en chambre
donc c'est des choses avec elle
personnellement je suis en train de
m'adapter mais je pense aussi bouger
dehors de mes collègues aux syndicats
mélanie joly murcie où ces informations